in 1977 i met a french chef
he said to me cooks cook to nurture
people
that moment is when i decided to become
a professional chef
it's an emotional connection that you
have to have with food
first and foremost this is the first
time i've
ever done anything like this i've always
felt that we are a product of those
who've inspired us i stand on the
shoulders of countless chefs who came
before me
i have better knowledge i have better
skills because of them and that's my job
to pass it on
i focus on techniques rather than
recipes because it's really the
techniques that are the most important
part of any recipe
salt enhances acid enhances pepper
changes flavor or adds another flavor
[Music]
the amount of oil that a yolk will take
is almost
infinite glazing
is surprisingly challenging even for
professional cooks
the aromas the sound is really important
any one of these techniques is something
that i know is achievable
every technique that i'm sharing with
you we use in our restaurants
we want to give you very simple dishes
with very few ingredients
it really ignites that emotional
connection to food
so pan roasting is a technique to give
you creamy
almost pudding-like zucchini
if you go through the steps if you take
your time if you're patient
you will succeed everything here that
i'm teaching
is something that'll last you a lifetime
i want you to be able to master each
technique
you will gain the confidence and the
courage to express yourself
i'm thomas keller and this is my master
class
you